alors là mitterrand vous rentrer d'haïti
où vous avez assisté jeudi à
l'investiture du père aristide nouveau
président de cette république des
caraïbes
c'était qu'asiatique mène depuis
longtemps dans le pays des actions à
caractère humanitaire l'une de ses
principales préoccupations était et
reste bien sûr le sort des enfants de
port au prince livrés à eux mêmes avant
de connaître un destin national le père
aristide leur a donc d'abord donné une
famille haïti reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
jean marc pitte et georges milan fils de
paysan leurs parents les ont confiés à
une famille citadine de port au prince
pour qu'ils y reçoivent une éducation la
difficulté des corvées pour leur
confiait et les coupes il recevait les
ont fait fuir enfants des bidonvilles
ils doivent gagner eux mêmes leur
nourriture orphelins ils n'ont d'autre
solution que la rue à l'époque pas si
lointaine des duvalier il était souvent
ramasser et parquet parce que devenu
indésirable en période touristique
depuis quelques années une porte s'est
ouverte
bien avant d'être élu président de son
pays le prêtre jean bertrand aristide
qu'on soit l'idée d'un centre ouvert
pour accueillir ces jeunes hostiles à
tout encadrement la forme hisser la vie
leur offre un toit où dormir se nourrir
se laver s'abriter ils y viennent
volontairement et peuvent en sortir à
leur gré la possibilité leur est donnée
d'apprendre à lire et à écrire
l'élection triomphale de leur parent les
a transformés en symboles à la veille de
son investiture
un incendie a éclaté dans l'un de leurs
dortoirs cinq d'entre eux y sont restés
ce drame a malheureusement endeuillé la
visite de la présidente de france
libertés dans leurs nouvelles fermes
l'association de danielle mitterrand a
participé à la construction de ce lieu
destiné à familiariser les petits
vagabond avec la vie professionnelle
si son passé en quelques années de
l'indifférence générale à l'attention
internationale
ces jeunes exclus savent à qui ils le
doivent celui qui les a recueillies qui
a été le premier à se pencher sur leur
mise elle s'est vue conduit à la tête de
l'état par un véritable raz de marée
près de 70% des haïtiens ont voté pour
lui en décembre dernier à 37 ans le
prêtre jean bertrand aristide porte sur
ses épaules l'espoir de tout un peuple
ces premiers et plus jeunes fidèles lui
ont porté eux-mêmes son fauteuil
présidentiel
un président qui tranche avec ses
prédécesseurs les pelouse du palais
était autrefois le domaine réservé des
macoutes et des militaires
elles sont devenues jeudi dernier le
jour de l'investiture de titid le
terrain de jeu des petits vagabond le
protocole y a peut être perdu haïti il
ya certainement gagné
france libertés travaille depuis
longtemps avec l'association